hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about
how to use spirit blue auger to conduct
a life pace test so spirit blue auger
is a differential medium meaning it's
like a medium that you can use to grow
bacteria in the laboratory
differential because it allows you to
distinguish between
two different types of bacteria as we
will see
but to understand this first we need to
talk a little bit about triglycerides
so triglycerides are a
kind of lipid macromolecule
that can be used as an energy source
and also as a source of carbon
as long as they can be broken down this
right here
is kind of a generic triglyceride so
it's composed
of two major things there is
a glycerol molecule
on there that has reacted and sterified
with three fatty acids
and those are these long tails right
here and so this is what a triglyceride
looks like
we as humans eat food with triglycerides
all the time and break it down
and can use this as a source of energy
by breaking down these bonds that
releases energy
and as a carbon source because these
long tails that i've drawn right here
are long hydrocarbon chains so very
carbon rich in there
so these can be broken down by an enzyme
called
lipase
so lipase or lipase it breaks down
lipids
and then now we're thinking about this
from the point of view of bacteria okay
because bacteria can do this too
certainly humans break down
triglycerides all the time some bacteria
can do this also because they have light
base
and some bacteria cannot do this because
they lack lipase
so from the point of view of the
bacteria they can
secrete this life-based enzyme if they
have the gene for it
to break down triglycerides and then the
individual components like the glycerol
and the fatty acids
those can actually then cross the
bacterial cell wall
and once they cross the cell wall they
can be used
they can enter glycolysis or
enter the krebs cycle depending on which
one we're talking about here
and they can then be used to
um extract energy so they can be used as
an energy source
in the process of aerobic respiration
so now let's talk a little bit more
about the spirit blue auger
bacteria can be either lipase positive
meaning they have this enzyme so they
can break down triglycerides
and use them for energy and carbon an
example of a lipase positive bacterium
would be bacillus
subtilis
bacteria can also be lipase negative
meaning that they do not have lipase and
they cannot break down this thing
and use it for energy and carbon an
example of a lipase negative bacterium
would be
salmonella typhomorium
now let's talk about the spirit blue
auger it
has a dye in it called spirit blue dye
which makes it
blue and that is our indicator
meaning that it's the spirit blue dye is
a change to the spirit blue dye
that is going to tell us whether lipase
is present or not
there's also some kind of emulsified
lipid this is something like um corn
oil or olive oil
just some source that's very rich in
triglycerides
and then there's going to be ochre and
remember auger is just a solidifying
agent so it keeps the
the media solid instead of liquid and
then the bacteria can grow
on there and so um
the the method for a light paste test is
to use spirit blue agar
and then to do what i'd like to say are
our three eyes
so first inoculate
so you inoculate with the test bacteria
and that means just taking a loop
getting some of your test bacteria and
then
streaking it down the plate so maybe we
do this with
species a and we do this with species b
so we've got two streaks on there two
different types of bacteria that we're
testing
so that's the inoculation the second eye
you can probably guess
is incubate
so incubate at you know roughly 30 35
degrees to 37 degrees somewhere in that
little window
for 24 hours then you come back and our
third eye
is identify
and this is where you're just going to
observe the plate to see what happened
specifically you're looking for the
presence of halos around the streak
so if you come back
and the first streak that you did
for we'll say bacterial species a
maybe it looks like this
so you've got a halo around it and that
is because
they have been able to break down the
triglycerides
and that results in a change to the
spirit blue dye that indicator
that results in this clearing halo so
where you see a halo
that indicates that that
species is lipase
positive
so life is positive meaning that it has
light pace it can break this down
that's why you get a halo if you're
interested in learning um from some of
my other videos you can check out videos
that i have on aerobic respiration that
will tell you all about
glycolysis and the krebs cycle you can
also check out a different video that is
specifically aerobic respiration in
bacteria
which tells you a little bit more about
how bacteria
have slightly different processes that
contribute
and enable their aerobic respiration i
also have
more videos than i can count on
different kinds of auger and different
kinds of
bacterial tests using kind of
differential augers to determine
to to identify specific strains or to
separate different strains
so please check out some of those if you
are interested and thank you for
watching biology professor